Orista cung cấp nhôm đồng Enoch đủ dài kích thước, cắt theo yêu cầu chỉ từ một
tấm.
Trong sản xuất công nghiệp, vật liệu không chỉ cần đúng mát, mà còn phải đúng dạng,
đúng kích thước và đúng quy cách để phù hợp với từng công đoạn sản xuất.
Tại Orista, nhôm đồng và thép được cung ứng đa dạng về chủng loại, dạng vật liệu
và kích thước, đáp ứng từ nhu cầu vật liệu tiêu chuẩn đến yêu cầu gia công cụ
thể.
Với dạng tấm, Orista cung cấp đa dạng quy cách, từ chiều dày 1-600mm, thiều rộng
11-600mm và chiều dài lên đến 6mm, với kích thước và dung sai được kiểm soát
theo tiêu chuẩn Orista hoặc là yêu cầu kỹ thuật của khách hàng.
Với sẻ cuộn, Orista gia công theo yêu cầu về khổ rộng, chiều dài, khối lượng,
chất lượng theo yêu cầu, kiểm soát tốt dung sai độ lượng, ba via khổ sẻ, đảm bảo
bề mặt đẹp, đóng gói và bảo quản trong môi trường kiểm soát nhiệt độ cùng độ ẩm
tiêu chuẩn.
Gia công phay chính xác 4-6 mặt, đảm bảo độ vuông góc, độ phẳng, kiểm soát ba
via, đảm bảo độ ổn định của sản phẩm sau gia công.
Bên cạnh gia công cơ khí, Orista còn xử lý nhiệt kim loại giúp tăng độ cứng, ổn
định cơ tính, giảm ứng suất dư, đảm bảo chất lượng và độ bền sản phẩm sau xử lý.
Xử lý bề mặt kim loại bằng phương pháp thấm ni tơ chân không, giúp tăng độ cứng
bề mặt, cải thiện khả năng chống mài mòn, nâng cao tuổi thọ chi tiết, hạn chế
biến dạng, từ một tấm đến số lượng lớn, từ cung ứng vật liệu đến gia công hoàn
thiện.
Orista đáp ứng theo từng mark vật liệu, quy cách và tiêu chuẩn kỹ thuật của từng
đơn hàng.
Nếu doanh nghiệp bạn đang cần mua hay gia công kim loại theo yêu cầu, liên hệ
ngay hotline 0988 750 686 để nhận tư vấn.